welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host his and this is the final
installment this year of our early on in
recruitment Series so in this series
we've been interviewing and speaking to
recruiters who are early on in their
career so in their first six 12 18
months and I'm really excited to be
joined by will today who I'm going to
get to introduce himself in a second
um just because he has achieved some
pretty amazing uh achievements in his
time in Recruitment and I know a lot of
people will have loads of different
questions and be really interested to
hear sort of world's Journey So Far So
before we go into all of that we'll uh
for those that may not know who you are
uh tell us a bit about yourself how long
you've been working in recruitment these
types of things and then we'll we'll get
into the stuff that I know a lot of
people are going to be really
interesting in listening to
sure yeah so I guess just a bit about
myself you know born and raised in Texas
uh us and then
um have stayed here my entire life went
to college went to University College in
Texas and then
um you and I are actually just chatting
about where I've traveled but so I am
well traveled been around the been
around the world but
um yeah I've been in recruitment for
about a year and a half now and uh have
loved it
um so doing doing some good stuff there
love it so
how I became aware of you is uh we're
friends of Oliver cook here we've had
him on the podcast who I know is the
managing director of the office and and
sort of business function or the the
part of the business that I know you're
uh part of
and I saw his post where he was talking
about William Johnson which is you yeah
and about some and like just
highlighting some of the amazing
achievements that you've worked your
absolute socks off to achieve sure so
I'm just going to share some of these
and then like
just just so people can get the context
why I was like right let's let's get a
wheel on the pods uh and then we can
just get you to share a bit about your
Market whether you're recruiting and
then we'll get into all the good stuff
so this is the post that I saw from
Oliver where he said uh what you've
achieved in 17 short months
largest ever single deal in fade in
Dallas history largest single paycheck
in fail in Dallas history for fastest
person to a million dollars build in
Dallas history
um you're now a player coach already
managing two Juniors you've helped 16
candidates find amazing new roles
qualified for the fading International
summer holiday in Cancun currently in
pole position to be the top performer
top biller in uh fade in Dallas this
year and you've even got a deposit on
your first house and put it down that
week so I saw that post of a picture of
you with some balloons and apparently
you don't drink so you had like a steak
I think on on your on your desk
so like that they're like some pretty
like unreal achievements right in this
sort of period that you've been on and
this isn't going to be a conversation
where we just have will tell us how
great he is everyone just just so just
so you're aware right we're always about
uncovering the challenges and I know
you've had challenges along the way but
just for this will help people like tell
us a bit about the word you recruit in
the niche that you operate in maybe like
what your average deal size is and just
tell us some of those some of that
context because I think that would be
really helpful for people
yeah sure so
um I'm in I'm a permanent recruiter so
in the financial technology space
um working my head hedge funds
proprietary trading firms investment
Banks
um and then also a variety of different
fintech firms and uh been dabbling in
crypto and blockchain as well and and
helping kind of get
that off the ground here in Texas our
New York teams phenomenal in that sense
um but yeah my average deal size if
we're going off the numbers is around
58k
I would say it's probably more so around
that 50k Mark with a with a couple of
big splashes
um there here and there so
um yeah it's it's been fun
yeah I have nothing to complain about
here yeah so okay cool so that that's
really helpful so let let's just let's
just start then with like
how has this like you said you've you've
always been in in Texas
Dallas went to University there so like
firstly how has this career in
recruitment being compared to like what
you expected when you first went to the
Dallas office like I don't know what
were the expectations and how has it
been to those initial expectations when
you when you join the industry
yeah I think I'd have to back up a
little bit right so I got my degree in
Psychology and then I went and actually
got a master's in marriage and family
therapy
um and was going to be a therapist had
this like idea that I was going to be a
therapist and and do that and then uh I
decided after I graduated it was like
Peak covid and
um I was like I'm not ready to enter the
workforce so I'm gonna go and do more
education and
um then like halfway through the first
semester I was like why am I here
dropped out of that that University and
uh and that degree and then
um happenstance just fell into
recruitment
um I think that's a common theme common
story amongst uh most of us and so
uh I I had no expectation
um I walked in
to the the final interview and did a
couple of mock calls and was like okay
yeah I could it seems simple enough I
could do this
um and then
uh you know walked in on my first day
and was like
okay this is gonna be harder than than I
thought it was gonna be like I'm I'm
gonna have to put in a bit of work and
grind for a bit and I my my mindset was
that exactly like I loved it
um I the the grind is something that
um you kind of just fall in love with
but I I was looking for that when I
started
I don't think I could sit in a in an
office job where uh
where I could get all my work done in
you know two hours and there'd not be
nothing else for me to do that day I
would I would get really bored
um and so I I think
per my expectations not really having
any but it exceeding those expectations
regardless in terms of what I wanted to
do and where I found myself and just how
I can uh
work hard and be rewarded for that work
I'm I'm just quickly curious well
when you tell your friends that you fell
into recruitment or you got a job in
recruitment like what what's the
perception in the US or what what did
your friend say how did they react like
yeah what what's the what was the
perception from your friends when you
told them about this uh job that you've
uh taken
um
I think I started talking about the
money first
it that that's that's when I really
started talking about my job was when I
started talking about
how much money I was actually making and
the potential for the amount of money
that I could make
and and then that that got my friends
interested
and uh funny enough I actually referred
probably
seven or eight of my buddies
um two faden and two to where I'm at now
and a couple of them were working here
and my best friends in contracts
recruitment
um you know and so they
they they took well to it and you know
you talk about money people want to make
money talk about the potential so the
the reason why I ask is I think having
interviewed American into recruiters
the perception the perception in the UK
from what I understand the perception of
the UK is definitely the perception of
the industry and the career is is
definitely different compared to the US
just because in the UK we as an industry
and the big part of what we're trying to
change with this podcast is it doesn't
have the best reputation so in the UK
that experience might be like oh there's
no way you're doing that will is there
or like why would you do that I hate
recruiters my experiences have always
been bad but I do think in the US
particularly from what I understand
sales which recruitment falls into is
definitely perceived as like a legit
respectable career in the US more so in
the UK this has been my this this has
been my experience from speaking to
people so that's why I was curious to
ask having been someone that clearly
told your friends about wanting to be a
therapist you really invested a lot in
education to then say I've now got this
job I was just curious to see what your
sort of friends or yeah what what the
sort of society would have said well I
don't know yeah I was just curious so
that's why I asked so thanks for sharing
yeah one and I agree with you
um like
people in America don't necessarily know
that much about recruitment as a career
not yet and so there isn't
I guess a bias or a prerogative towards
it yet uh and then also you know there's
been plenty of people who have been
successful in sales and so
um selling that they're talking about it
with a new grad to talk to their parents
about or talk to their friends about
there it's definitely more open-minded
so so let's get in let's get into this
so first thing that I want to get your
thoughts on you told us about the market
that you recruited then and you told me
you did a master a degree in Psychology
and you wanted to be a therapist that is
the polar opposite of crypto Financial
Tech propriety of tech investment funds
these things people in those Industries
might have a therapist but like that
that wasn't your world is that fair to
say absolutely so the first thing I want
to find out from you is what was Will's
strategy and the principles that you
used to really make sure that you became
as knowledgeable as you needed to be to
build confidence to speak to these
people because a lot of people a lot of
recruiters I speak to an interview that
are early on sometimes are paralyzed by
the fact that they know a lot less than
the people they're calling and that can
sometimes over yeah that can sort of
yeah paralyze them as I say and sort of
reduce their confidence which impacts
performance so first thing I want to
know from you was like what was your
approach what was your strategy because
you clearly didn't know a lot about this
world what did you do on a daily weekly
basis early on that you feel like gave
you
um yeah more confidence or the
confidence that you needed to remove
that fear and just go straight go
straight into it
yeah great question I think Ollie Ollie
cook would attest to my inability to to
speak on the phone when I first started
and and the the lack of market knowledge
that I held was it was tough to say the
least uh in
I think my approach to it was just
getting the Reps in I treated it like
working out or like going to the gym and
and working out that muscle of the more
I do it the more comfortable I'm gonna
get with it and then in terms of
gathering the market knowledge in order
to be confident about talking about
something you need to know a lot about
it and that was explained to me really
early on in my career of
the more you know the more confident
you're going to sound on the phone and
the more people are going to buy into
you and and so I treated it like school
um if I'm being real honest I I took
what study habits I had and and also
just the ability to learn that I have
and applied it to learning my market in
a very deep manner to where I was
teaching people on desk on my team about
the market or about different
Technologies or about what I learned
just because
I'd kind of taken the extra 30 minutes
60 Minutes at the end of the day or at
the beginning of the day to read an
article or to dive a bit deeper into
something that I had figured out
um I think another strategy that I used
was talking to candidates if I saw
something on a resume or a CV and
um or a candidate mentioned something in
a call I would ask them I think I got
over that fear of
not knowing what I was saying pretty
quickly because I just I I was I'm a
pretty pragmatic guy and recognize that
I I don't know what I'm talking about
and would tell candidates that but I
also think
that came from
my Master's Degree as well is in in
practice
um you know if we don't know something
we we don't want to fake it
um we want to like ask more questions
around it really be curious about it and
so I think uh that curious mindset
helped me as well
really interesting so you mentioned that
ollywood the test for your uh inability
to get on the phone will speak to people
yeah like let's let's just paint a
picture because I think to hear at the
beginning what you achieved and to hear
that you went through that would maybe
be surprising to some people
so one how long were you how long were
being honest with us like how long would
you say where like maybe you maybe let
that fear overcome you a bit or there
might be other things at play and then
two let's just hear about like what that
actually looked like and what you feel
like really helped you like push through
it and you didn't let that be your story
then so first how long was that period
would you say
I mean I was on I was on the phones in
my first week
and so it was very much so like
we're calling people and we're we're
gonna get over that quickly
um and in Ollie so to give context when
I started we were in office of 25 here
in Dallas and so Ollie sat right next to
me and was very involved in my training
and then as we've grown to over 100
people in Dallas now it's it's
um
you know it's been a lot a little bit
different but Ollie will you know just
kept encouraging me uh and I honestly
think that he did a really good job of
mentoring me and making sure that I even
though I was saying the wrong things he
would ask me questions and challenge me
and focus on that so it was really in
the first week I was still on the phones
it was just uncomfortable
um and I it was it was it was it
downright uh bad but
I kind of got embarrassed and if you
know speaking can't I appreciate being
on this yeah it is I would get
embarrassed like I've got this guy with
10 years of experience sitting next to
me who's the managing director of the
office and he's looking at me like
what are you saying
um and like
um
and that's how he is and he and I joke
about that a lot now and I I would get
embarrassed and so that's that's what
drove me to
and you could take that one of two ways
right you could take it of
oh I'm embarrassed like I'm just not
going to talk or I'm embarrassed I'm
going to figure out what I can talk
about
um and I think that that's a Difference
Maker of why my story was not you know
leaving after six months and why my
story was the success that story that it
is now was because the mindset that I
took was okay cool I'm embarrassed right
now but I'm going to use that
embarrassment to motivate me to uh to
get better and to find a way to not be
embarrassed
um yeah I appreciation I think we will
be now I can definitely resonate with
that when I was in recruitment was an
office of a sat down and that's the
owner of the business and those first
few calls even voicemails like it's
brutal you just you think everyone is
listening to you and maybe laughing
inside of how terrible you sound or how
bad you are so I I totally get that and
love that mindset again which is a big
part of what this is about which is
instead of letting that
be your story or be the reason why you
can't you've met you've sort of used
that as fuel and motivation
um as to like why you're gonna push
through it and yeah so I I love that so
I guess another bit of context that
would be helpful will so go on the
phones quite quickly like are you over
this this period have you been someone
and have you been expected and at what
stage were you expected if at all to
bring on your own clients and do new
business so like in I don't know if it's
the same in and I don't think it's
always the same in the us but we use
terminology here as like a 360 recruiter
which would mean you bring on your own
clients you Source your own candidates
you do like the full deal is that been
your journey
yeah yeah so
um
to start not necessarily I am a 360
recruiter and I do bring on my own
business when I started I had a pretty
good job platform to start with
and that definitely helped an
accelerated my career and and my
earnings and my Billings but I have
brought on and am expected to bring on
new business as part of my day-to-day
and just what I do it probably took me
uh so I started April of 2021 and then I
brought on my first client in
um
I want to say October late October
and then I didn't do my first 360 deal
until February
February this year yeah yeah February
this year and then okay that's that's
honestly when I started seeing my
earnings go up and like when I started
when when I wasn't reliant on
jobs that other people had pulled and
you wasn't getting the split the split
okay exactly
so let's talk a bit about this then so
let's just focus a bit on the candidate
side first curious with hindsight
knowing what you know now if we were to
take those first 90 days or maybe even
first six months
what do you think maybe you would do
differently or what would be your
strategies or approach
knowing what you know now that you think
would enable will to get even more out
of the candidate activity in the time he
was investing in
the candidates sourcing the relationship
building that led to success or the
placements like yeah no we know now
would would you do anything differently
would you approach that that period
those first couple of months uh yeah
definitely on on the candidate side out
of interest and feel free to go as as
practical as you want here if it was I
would really focus more on the candidate
qualification calls and uncovering the
candidate drivers I don't know anything
that comes up with hindsight that you
think you would maybe do differently
that would would have brought success
even more quickly
sure uh yeah and before before answering
that question I want to address
um so the there isn't like a split fee
for like if if someone else had pulled a
job or if it was a job from a key
account or a key client it wasn't
necessarily a split fee if I placed it I
would still get that full fee
um there's you know that here nor there
I just wanted to make sure that was okay
no yeah sorry that was that was my
assumption apologies no no all good
um and then yeah in terms of like in in
the first
30 60 90 days what I what I to clarify
what I wish I'd done differently or
whatever yeah maybe like just looking
back is there anything because this is
what people want to know like is there
anything that maybe yeah looking back
you think you could have done better or
improved on or doubled down on the you
think would because a lot of people it's
the same in the UK where a lot of people
were like I did as well a lot of people
do start on the candidates side
hopefully have like a good job job
platform to get started working right
into and and get the Reps in so we're
just curious to sort of hear your
thoughts on if there's anything that
maybe do differently double down on with
hindsight
yeah 100 I I would say closing on the
first call
um or or focusing on closing before
the you know final call after the final
interview and you pick up the phone
you're like do you want the job and
they're like no
okay
um I in my first year I generated over a
million dollars in terms of deals and
only closed 350k of it
wow and so yeah it was it was it was
tough
and and for so very genuinely in my
first 30 60 90 days
uh you know closing and focusing on
that the close isn't
the ultimate thing it's the process
um and asking the right questions and
not putting my head in the sand and
um and and really making sure that
I know the reasons why my candidate
isn't going to take the offer versus
just asking the candidate why they would
take the offer and hearing all the happy
positive things
but being more attuned and and ready to
hear the negative things of and the
objections that I could then overcome so
that that's that's what I would have
wanted to
what I know now what I would have wanted
to put in practice earlier I think also
yeah go ahead
no no sorry
no yeah
um
sorry if it's a little loud and we're
doing a deal right now but
um I would say the the other thing is
learning that I can influence people
way way earlier in the process than
um than I thought and I think that ties
in with closing and it ties in with that
aspect but our CEO said you know once
they learned that he could influence
the process in people that's when it
changed for him and I would agree once I
felt as though I could say no to a
candidate or push back or be
a bit more
upfront and personal with someone I
think if you know I'd learned that early
on and implemented that early on it
would have helped
so was it thank you for sharing that I'm
being honest so what do you think it was
more like you mentioned a few things
there so was it more the will early on
was really good at just listening to
what he wanted to listen to just hear
the things that he wanted to hear and
was less reluctant to ask the questions
that maybe you didn't want to hear the
answer to or maybe even they didn't even
think that you could yeah like influence
as you said I don't know was it was it
was it those types of things or was
there anything else so when you say
closing was it yeah was it it was just
something that you didn't I don't know
take seriously or you always just opted
for like the positive and you didn't
look at the reasons as to why they may
not take that job opportunity you were
speaking to them about
yeah I just always opted for the
positive yeah I just didn't want to hear
the negative so
that's so common yeah because I think
I'm sure there's many times that you got
off the phone despite Ole said you got
this amazing candidate I said they're
already it's done
yep eight weeks 12 weeks later you're
robbing the deal that was on the board
off the board
yep
okay I appreciate you sharing that so I
guess the the advice there then will is
like really lean into that and be
willing to hear the things you don't
want to hear to hear and yeah don't fall
into the Trap of just wanting to hear
the positives and being an Undertaker
not yeah
yeah I would I would say get
uncomfortably personal with your
candidates
like understand how many dogs they have
and and you know that that that's yeah I
joke but at the same time like
understand that about your candidates or
you know who else is making the decision
with them you know do they have a
partner are they do they have kids like
it it's those simple money things that
we don't think about that came and would
bite me in the butt so um
yeah so let's just talk about this for a
second I don't want you to think about
it for too long because it although it
might be really painful
but let's just talk about it because a
lot of people have to go through this
and then this is common yep
like that must have been like so painful
like realizing what you could have build
and what you did
so let's just talk about this in terms
of again why like why did will not quit
like why why why did when those down
days happen when did the like these
things happen why why did you carry on
and what what did you do to help you
make sure or help ensure that that drop
deal or that month where maybe two fell
out or whatever wasn't then the reason
why will didn't perform for the rest of
the month using the funk for the rest of
the month like just talks a bit about
that because that is something that I
know is difficult and something and and
a lot of the time a reason as to why
people leave the industry
so like let's just talk about some of
these really challenging moments and
days where yeah you had to push through
them and again you didn't let it be the
story of Will's career at faden where
you could have been this person that
built a million but you build 350 in
your first year and you quit
yeah
um
I took uh again it goes back to your
mindset it took him as learning
opportunities
um it it like I could have taken it as I
could have blamed everyone else except
myself
um and I have a buddy on desk
in the office who talks about extreme
ownership you know pulled from Draco and
um that aspect of extreme ownership is
so important because
if I'm owning everything and I'm
responsible for it then then it's really
I can only blame myself
um and so taking those as learning
opportunities versus
taking you know more of a victim
mentality where you know the world's
against me like that's that's just more
draining like if I own it and am
responsible for it and learn from it
then I can move on from it but if I take
a more victim mentality towards it then
I'm going to dwell on it it's going to
weigh me down and I'm going to
eventually it's going to push me out of
the the industry and so
um I don't know where it clicked or how
it happened but I I would just take
responsibility for it I would talk with
my manager about it we would process
through it kind of do it an autopsy
almost of of the Dead process and and
make sure that did I do everything that
I could have done in my power to make
sure that the candidate took the offer
no okay cool where where can I learn and
improve for the next time and so that's
that was my process and and that was
implemented with with my manager of uh
and I can give credit to them for that
so
yeah no I love that I'm I'm a big
big believer in that that mindset as
well just because I think the way that I
think about it is if you don't have that
mindset and you do have more of that
victim mindset as you said you're giving
so much power to other people yep and
you're removing That Power from yourself
so I love that and I think I'm really
glad that you shared that because I
think if more people do have that
mentality in our industry then there's
just going to be way more opportunity
for people to learn rather than be like
you just said like really heavy and like
this is so hard so difficult I don't
want to do it anymore
uh it's a whole then different story on
if you do keep having those little top
season you keep making the same mistakes
that's when you need to be an
environment where you're getting help
and support and these things but I think
to have a chance with dealing with those
down days in recruitment I think the
best chance you've got is taking a
stream ownership
yep
so I yeah I think that's brilliant so
talk talk to me talk to me a bit about
then your new business Journey because
that that's difficult for a lot of
people
like obviously it was a little while
before you uh obviously
um started working with your your first
client like what what were some of your
your biggest challenges when it comes to
will becoming someone that was
self-efficient of bringing on his own
clients what are some of your biggest
obstacles at the beginning
uh
it's gonna sound but time management
um I just couldn't find the time or
couldn't be bothered to find the time to
do it
um and so
it was sitting down and creating a plan
over you know a week or two weeks with
um
and just really understanding that okay
from this hour to this hour this is what
I'm going to be doing
and and being very strict with my time
in that sense
um and then also creating my own luck so
having enough output to where
um you know the luck would come back and
someone would respond and then beyond
that
getting together I started focusing a
bit more in the crypto and blockchain
space and and wanting that to be the
kind of clients that I bring on
um and having that specific Focus helped
me
organize my time better and organize
where I was gonna attack the market and
what Market I wanted to build out
um in recognizing that okay that's a
growing Market
there'll be some good business
development ones there that I can grow
and and build into accounts that you
know service my team now so
the time management piece is really
common and really typical there's
there's a you go from just focusing on
maybe like a particular like a few sort
of job
um opportunities you're working on to
speak to similar candidates from your
experience looking for similar
experience to then within the same day
having to do that but then also win your
own business then work on the clients
that you're working with and sign terms
with so that that sort of leads quite
nicely into my next question like will
people love Day plans on this podcast
people love a day plan breakdown I think
everyone wants to hear or want would
like to think that there's a golden
bullet right but I don't think there is
like you said you have to put the output
in to create your own luck but I'd love
to just hear again because this would be
free trial and error what would become
your sort of non-negotiable activity is
that you feel like give you the best
chance of creating your own luck
talk to us a bit about what a typical
day looks like in terms of how much wait
and time you put towards certain
activities from a 360 perspective tell
us about your day will people would love
to to learn and hear that
yeah I think my day has definitely
changed
um as I've brought on to two Juniors
let's do it before the two genes because
I think for the two a lot of people a
lot of people early on won't have genius
so let's just what did Will's day look
like what were the activities he was
doing before you didn't have before
mental responsibilities and you would
just focused on being an individual
contributor yeah easy enough so
you get in at eight
um
and
eight to eight thirties checking email
add response focusing on kind of
organizing the day and then at 8 30 is a
pretty much an office wide core hour so
it's a non-negotiable of like candidate
calling from 8 30 to 9 30.
UM 9 30 to 10 is going to be some admin
from getting resumes out and then at 10
I'm doing business development focusing
on new client generation and then
that'll that'll consist of either
sending out spec CVS marketing Market
intelligence or
flipping pancaking
um
you know more senior candidates and then
11 to 12 is is
ad response and sending out emails in
that sense
um 12 to 1 I'll grab lunch and then one
to you know 5 36 is is
basically just my morning but replicated
into my afternoon but focusing on
different
um
focusing on different clients so like if
if my 8 30 and the 930 core hour was for
one specific client I was calling for
calling candidates for it then you know
from one to two thirty I'm calling for a
different client that I'm working with
right now
um and then beyond that you know my
uh my business development might look
like cold calls versus spec CVS or or
it'll turn into let's do some warm
Business Development and and expand in
mushroom uh accounts that we're already
working with and see where we can you
know get in with a different hiring
manager in that sense so it's it's not a
foolproof plan and it typically gets
blown up by some tar some sort of
Process Management or some sort of uh
um you know crisis that's going on but
at the end of the day like that that's a
pretty
rough plan of what I do I would say the
morning is the most important
yeah
awesome
where what what's been again I know
there isn't like a golden bullet but
from your experience so far your Market
I know there's nuances what has been
like the most effective way for you to
land that all important or first client
meeting with a New Prospect what what's
enabled you to
uh yeah what would you say what comes up
for you when we think about the most
sort of consistent and successful way
you've been able to get that first
client meeting and and start opening
those doors
[Music]
um
persistence it you know we're told to
follow up and follow up and follow up
and people don't follow up
um I think if you follow up more than
you know five times and someone doesn't
respond you can send an email saying
like hey I'm not going to follow up
anymore I just want to let you know that
like this is the last email you'll
receive from me
um I've been utilizing that technique a
lot lately and that's been a couple
email so yeah yeah it's yeah it's
and I think it's also just being
courteous
um to people right like the other the
other end of the email is a person and I
know I don't like getting spammed and I
think you know following up five six
times is plenty for them to you know
recognize that they either want to do
business with you or they don't want to
do business with you right now
um and so you can send them yeah a
breakup email and then
um after that follow up in three months
right like give them a little bit of a
break and so that's that's what I've
been founding finding effective
um is is just being persistent
um even even once I have like a a call
book then I'll follow up and I'll make
sure that we're still good to go and
then beyond that making sure that I have
you know weekly or bi-weekly follow-ups
and calls with my clients that I'm
bringing on
um just to calibrate and make sure that
we're sending the right candidates and
things like that so
and then just quickly well understand
definitely that's where a lot of people
fall short
so just two things if we might know
we're going quite granularly here but I
know it's what people want to learn so
firstly what's Will's follow-up
organization
like what'd you do to that do you have
like Outlook reminders use your CRM what
helps will know who he needs to call and
when just curious when it comes to like
following up and just giving yourself
the best chance of like actually
following up and being reminded to
yeah yeah I have Outlook reminders so
um it's it's a you know 15 minute
recurring calendar invite on my calendar
that extends until the end of time
um that that tells me how to follow up
and uh and then I know who just because
I I do it on a two-week period pretty
much
um like I'll I'll
I will hit five different clients three
or five different managers three to five
different times ways and then Monday
Wednesday Friday on the first week and
then every day the next week and then
I'll switch it up and I'll do five more
people or five different you know
clients the next two weeks and so I know
who I'm gonna be hitting up and I've got
my CRM organized in terms of lists that
I can call through or lists that I can
email and so yeah it's it's a it's a
pretty efficient system that once you
get set up
is pretty simple to operate but it's the
getting it set up we're doing the yeah
they're setting up on the doing
and then my follow-up question was just
like when you're following up it's like
I'm sure it I may be wrong here but I'm
sure it's not just like where you're
just calling these people and at some
point hoping they pick up like you said
you're trying different is it I don't
know maybe within this follow-up Journey
you're sending an email you're specking
out a candidate you might be trying to
speak to them as a senior candidate that
you might then find out about their
hiring goals like when we say you're
following up and multiple touch points
are you are you not going with the same
intention each time on like
my name is Will I work for fader and
this is why I think you should give me
90 seconds of your time as to like why
like do you know I mean like what yeah
yeah
it's it's definitely different and
sometimes it's not even with the
motivation of of pulling a job or
getting you know an MSA in place it's
it's
it sometimes it's just to network and
talk with senior people in Myspace
um you know the
the
sometimes you know I'm not getting terms
in place until six months down the line
right or I'm following up with a
candidate that I worked with who I had
an offer for and now they're at a
different company as a lead engineer and
hiring for their team and it's like okay
cool like
but let's talk like how are you doing
how have you been and
um
Ollie cook says your network is your net
worth and I imagine he got that from
somewhere as well but it it is true
um I think connecting with senior people
in in a non
um
in a way that you aren't trying to get
something from them but maybe have
something to add value for them maybe
you have Market intelligence maybe you
know something about their competitor
that they might want to know
um it's it's
a give and a take and a lot of the times
we take and and don't necessarily give
or provide and and I think that that's
set me apart is I like to give more than
I take
with my clients
now I'm glad you said that about the
long-term piece because uh like when you
early on you like you now you now have
the benefit of having the evidence of it
taking a while sometimes or maybe your
best client did take six months so when
you feel like you're not getting
anywhere with a particular like dream
client you know that you've got evidence
now to point out that goes well no will
it took you six months with this client
it's like keep going and sometimes when
you're early on it can really feel
thankless and you you don't have that
evidence yet to be like no keep going
because I'm going to crack my unlock so
so I'm glad that that you shared that so
I guess as we come to the end here then
we'll I'm just curious I don't know if
this is something that's come up for you
but I'd be interesting to hear your take
on
what what are you being mindful of to
make sure like some of these
achievements have been big no denying it
so you there's a couple of things
there's this question or a couple of
thoughts are coming up for me they're
just interested to hear your thoughts on
what are you doing to make sure will
does not become complacent and to be the
guy in the office that thinks he's
completed Recruitment and he's only done
it for 17 months because he's got these
accolades he's he's had his achievements
because you you could fall into that and
we've interviewed enough people on here
who have said that
one like when they became the top
performer or these types of things and
and where some of their biggest
challenges were when they became
complacent and and you could fall into
that I I don't I don't know how you feel
about that as I say that I don't know if
this is something you've been mindful of
like I don't know what comes up for you
when I share that and something that
just I don't know I I got thinking about
when thinking about your journey so far
because you you could you could become
that yeah well I appreciate the reminder
um my uh
my my manager and I have a you know
weekly bi-weekly meeting and pulled me
into a room I was like hey don't like
you're getting complacent basically
called me out for getting complacent
really
um in in like a very
teachable way oh yeah no and like yeah
and like he's like yeah but he's more so
talking to me about complacency and
helping me recognize that that's the
mindset that I'm slipping into and
um it was a really helpful conversation
and this is a really good reminder
um what would you so there's a button
but yeah I think people like what what
would you get in complacent like again
you've had that reminder being going
into that meeting and someone goes well
I'm going to hold up a mirror here and I
and I do feel like you you're getting
complacent this is what to be wary of I
understand why you might have gone like
this but what what was it when you then
left that environment actually thought
about it what was it that you was
actually being complacent with
uh
all of it
um a lot of my kpis went down a lot of a
lot of my numbers decreased and it
wasn't it wasn't the same standard that
I had been withhold with like that I
that I held myself to
um and so
yeah it
like a good amount of it just just went
straight down and
um
it's almost like relearning how to
recruit in a sense and and going back to
the basics is is how I'm
uh getting out of that complacent nature
is you know setting up a day plan that I
would have set up for myself when I was
you know 60 days in
um and and being very cognizant of my
mindset throughout the day of I don't
know everything and
always being willing to learn and you
know when someone holds up that mirror
to your face being willing to accept it
and look at it and explore it versus
just
you know slapping it down and and
telling them they're wrong and getting
frustrated and walking out because I
think again that
um that could weigh down on someone
versus you know building them up so um
so you're just final thing on this it is
really interesting that you said
that and again really appreciate you
being honest
I interviewed someone before who had on
their goals list for a long time to
become the top Biller and they achieved
it
and then the following year after that
they weren't and they really struggled
because
they then achieved that sort of Big Goal
that they had
and then they sort of realized or like
felt then they labeled themselves as a
top biller and if they weren't that like
what were they
so what I just from what you just told
me it was a bit of what we just spoke
about but also I feel like again if I'm
wrong here but I feel like you've had to
even though you're alone in your career
right because there's the achievements
that you've achieved you've had to
realign maybe the story that you tell
yourself as to like why didn't what
you're doing what your goals are because
you've checked off some of those things
quite quickly which then I'm not
surprised that you then had a dip
because
you like I'm sure at whatever period you
were like I'm gonna be the top performer
I'm going to do this you got then and
it's like [ __ ] I've got to go back in
the office tomorrow now and just do it
again and and crack on even though you
know
you you've achieved that milestone
yeah I don't know I don't know if that
resonates but I don't know if there's
anything to share there that you feel
like you've had to sort of recalibrate
on or maybe just look at
things that I don't know
no absolutely
um yeah more honestly that that's that's
spot on right
like uh my I hit my goals and was like
all right what's next
um and like had to come up with new
goals and I was like what goals do I
want to come up with now and
um the goal now is consistency
um it's it's focusing on
getting one like the uh the accumulation
of marginal gains so getting one percent
better every single day
um and then having the year-long
five-year-long goals are great
um but I think if you come in with the
daily goal of getting one percent better
every single day then you're you're
going that's the mindset that I've
adopted now is is
I'm not going to label myself as a top
biller or I'm not going to label myself
as someone who you know has had all of
this success but rather I'm I'm labeling
myself as someone who is going to get
one percent better every single day or
like try and have that mindset because I
think that's that's how I
can avoid another dip or that's how I
can avoid the disappointment of
potentially not being the top Builder
next year right like it's it's it's not
guaranteed
um just because I did it this year and
and or am potentially going to do it
this year
you are going to do it this year no I
appreciate you honestly there and I
think that's a great lesson for people
where for me you've you've made the goal
and what you're thinking about every day
less about the outcome and more about
the process 100
and that isn't to say like don't have
those Milestone goals on on your list
just don't make it all about that
um so I I think that's that's a great
great share so look let's end on the
heart let's end on our on the Highlight
there because I really feel like I've
I've held the mirror up against you and
I really appreciate you sharing it
because this would be really helpful for
people like tell us about your most
memorable day so far
um on this journey
there's there's a couple on I'll narrow
it down I'll give you one
um it's probably bringing the the
largest deal in Dallas history that was
that was a pretty
uh it was like a six month long process
with a candidate who
um you know was getting married and
there was a lot of you know talk about
the package and everything that was
going into that and
um I think ringing that deal was was a
really cool day because it was
um yeah it was really satisfying a lot
of work yeah can you get can you give us
a bracket
over on it was it was over 150.
under under 200. yeah so like yeah yeah
so six months work a lot of things that
could have gone wrong but
it was done yeah most memorable day one
of the most memorable days yeah one of
the most I I this is you know later on
in my career but the second most
memorable day is watching my juniors
just buzz about interview requests and
things coming in and and all of that it
almost like a a proud dad moment in that
sense so that was fun well I love that
you said that just because again this is
quite typical where
top billers top performers find
themselves enjoying those what those
experiences and those moments more than
the ones that they experience of
themselves yeah exactly see clearly on
that on that Journey which is awesome
and exciting look we'll just just want
to thank you so much thanks for being
really honest thanks for joining us on
there so I'm really excited to hear uh
the lessons and what people take away
from this conversation but kudosu will I
think in in the 17 18 months that you've
been in the industry you've had
challenges you've had Highs but clearly
what you've had to do is is really go on
this journey of working on will and uh
you know and that journey is never going
to end right which is is exciting but
also I think really cool and and I
really appreciate you sharing one of
those things with us so thanks a lot for
joining me yeah absolutely appreciate
you having me